so they're doing a documentary about me
and that was a weird thing man because
they didn't I mean nobody had any idea
that I was going to be going to the
White House it seemed a little
far-fetched as you can see and so then
so they started doing this documentary
about the movement the work that we're
trying to get done and I can see I can
see clearly now and you know that work
continues but then obviously you know
because of all the excitement of me
going there and then leaving the way I
did makes the documentary a lot more
interesting but you know rad let me give
it a big speech rate a big chalk I think
you know it's small enough and you guys
wouldn't be here if you didn't have some
sense about what I'm trying to get done
that maybe we should just start with
questions and just use the time and to
have a conversation and so to make it
fair the first person who wants to ask a
question anyway you can't ask cuz I give
a speech I know you whoever you are you
don't have a question you've got a very
clever insight that you came here to
deliver so you have now been
disqualified down the second person I'll
get too young here's a rule ask it I'm
gonna let three or four people ask
questions before I answer that way we
kind of get a sense of like where the
whole room is that and then I'll take a
run at it and then if I didn't get your
question well enough you can kind of
give me the thumbs down i'll give it
another shot but that that cool that way
we can actually have more of a
conversation you guys get lectured at
all the time all right so i think you're
a second first
my question is is you your the the Prime
advocate of green jobs in the United
States and what what about I mean green
jobs are there's all sorts of green jobs
but what about prioritizing green jobs I
mean which types of green jobs should
take priority over other types I mean is
it that that that's the first part of
the question and then the second part of
the question is we want to increase the
number of green jobs what about your
position on decreasing the number of
brown jobs or dirty jobs jobs that are
the antithesis of green jobs I'm for
that so we can knock that one up I'll
get to the other one so let's take you
know two three four more questions kind
of get a sense of where people are at
and that way when I'm talking I'm
actually talking to so there's somebody
right down there in the front as got a
little shawl yeah thanks I'm curious to
understand what you see as the means of
helping work with ex-offender
populations and understanding what kind
of policies we need at a national scale
around department of justice and
corrections to overcome that major
hurdle great thank you um as an aside
I'm from Dresden Tennessee which is
right next to my addressee but you
remember uh now is that in weekly County
yes sir yeah good all right Madison
County so good we're neighbors but uh um
so all of it with some militancy there a
bunch of solar plants they're growing
jobs at a time when all the rest of the
factory jobs are leaving right and yet
when you talk to people about climate
legislation and the steps we need to
catalyze the green economy all people
think of is rising energy prices so i
can say is what the what needs to be
done to combat the misconceptions of the
disinformation about what a green
economy will mean for people
this is a great question may be just as
a tag on to the first question or a
second question depending on how you're
counting it where do you see natural
resource based jobs fitting into this so
agriculture timber and land management
for conservation hi forgive my ignorance
but why did you go to the White House
and what is the status of green jobs on
their agenda Thanks okay let's take two
more just good once I start talking you
know it's gonna be terrible if you'll be
leaving out the back pick up more hi I
work at a local community foundation and
we were recently asked to come together
as funders to talk about green jobs in
our role you won't be there so if you
had an opportunity to talk to local
funders for nonprofits what would you
tell them about what they should do to
bring about a greener economy thank you
one more hey brother George okay van are
you help hey no do I first of all don't
bust me out okay God see the man got up
here and he lied and made me look good
said I'd only been gone for seven years
he misread his no 17 years I graduate
1993 and now here comes George who I've
known since those days who's gonna say
you know they'd be gone for 20 years dot
7 and made me look terrible so don't do
that let them think I'm younger than I
am and that's another question
thank you you know doing world war two
remember carbon history was was legal
the him industry in America was legal
and then the repeal and in the
institution of laws to criminalize hemp
and marijuana but it had a vast effect
on the products textiles excerpt etc
from World War two and now here we're
back to the question of regaining the
economy and the earth and agriculturally
I think the hemp is very friendly so I
want to ask a question don't you think
is about time for we r agreeing the
earth and explode to help back on the
planet
now see we're friends like this do you
see why I had the experience that I had
do you see now look I may look like a
masochist and a crazy fool but even for
you George I'm not gonna say nothing
about no help so we got to just leave
that we're just gonna leave that out
stop the tape rewind it and I was now
i'm just gonna start talking cuz the
question is gonna go downhill from here
yeah and there's an agricultural
question above they don't say nothing
about no help so we'll get to that one
hey hey George is good to see you
brother I love you man now George not
George and I go way way way back so let
me just take them encounter at random
ex-offender population formerly
incarcerated folks you know this is the
core and the soul of the moral challenge
to the green economy we're going to have
a green economy or we're not going to
have an economy right so in some ways
you know victory is assured because
either we're going to eat you we have
this green soap bubble in space call the
earth that we live on passed up hundred
years been acting kind of crazy
industrial society strip mining and
baking the planet and poison and
polluting it the old gray economy we
keep doing that we won't be here so if
we are going to be here at a hundred
years we will have a green economy that
will be one of the most significant
achievements and accomplishments in all
of human history but it will be
insufficient unless it is a green
economy
that dr. King would be proud of unless
it's a green economy that includes
everybody it has a place in it for
everybody the big challenge that you
have in the new century you're
inheriting a new younger people are
going to have to lead through is every
single problem eventually it's going to
boil down to a question of how do you
have seven eight nine billion people on
the same little tiny planet not destroy
the planet and not have a bunch of wars
all the time that is a huge leadership
challenge for you and the opportunity
that you have is to start off right just
start off with the right values and to
say the problem fundamentally is the
idea of disposability that we believe we
have throwaway resources throwaway
species which we don't and the
environmentalist have done a tremendous
job in helping us understand that we
don't but we also don't have any
throwaway people either we don't have
throwaway neighborhoods either we don't
have throwaway nations either it's all
precious and it's all sacred and as I've
mentioned in the film there's something
wrong with any movement that will go
nuts to insist that dead material gets a
second chance but will be silent when
the time comes to give living people a
second chance coming out of prison I
would argue that from a moral point of
view we want to build a green economy
that says first of all it's highly
irrational to spend in California they
were spending 120 thousand dollars per
year per kid in jail and prison let me
say it again 120 thousand dollars per
year per kid locked up in California's
prison you could send two or three kids
to Yale for the cost of sending one kid
to jail right just to be clear about
that as a lot of money my suspicion is
there
getting anywhere near as good an
education but you never know and if we
use that money to build a green economy
rather than a gulag economy we would
probably actually have less violence
less crime safer communities and we'd be
well on our way so I wanted to start
with that from a practical point of view
there are green re-entry programs to
google the term green reentry they're
green reentry programs they're cropping
up all across the country as people
recognize that people are going to be
leaving prisons they got to be able to
do something and we have all this work
that needs to be done the moral
challenge for the green economy is to is
to take all this work that needs to be
done retrofitting America repowering
America putting up millions of solar
panels tens of thousands of wind
turbines hundreds of wind farms
retrofitting every building so that
leaks less energy waste less water
that's a tremendous amount of work that
needs to be done it's the most important
work in the world to turn a leader in
global pollution into a leader in global
ecological solutions that transition is
the most important work it needs to be
done in the world and we have all these
people who need work so if we can
connect the people who most need work to
the work that most needs to be done
we'll be able to fight pollution and
poverty at the same time beat global
warming and the global recession at the
same time that those kinds of solutions
are available but we need to start with
what the so called the least of these if
we get it right for pookie for snoopy
for a josue for little run run you know
I'm talking about I don't know you
talking about yes you know I'm talking
about we get it right just like yeah
yeah I know you talk about poop you need
a job uau right yeah snoopy need a job
we get it right for the young brothers
in the young sisters who we have thrown
in the trash can
then you know the rest of the economy is
going to be alright so let's start from
the beginning to build in the equity to
build an equal opportunity and the young
woman who wrote a book called the new
Jim Crow and her name is Michelle
Alexander and I encourage everybody get
this book it really talks about how we
have a new system I'm talking about the
prison stuff I think it's important in
environmental forum to talk about it in
the 1800's we had nearly enslave Minh as
a number one problem kind of the barrier
that the dehumanization machine that we
had in our country and then in the 1990s
we had Jim Crow she makes her argument
in the 2000s this mass incarceration
machine you know that takes people you
know drug offenders like probably half
of this room you know drug offenders
like you and your roommate the true drug
offender you can't wait to get away from
this summer um takes drug offender
something takes drug offenders quote
unquote and if they are four blocks from
you here in New Haven puts them in
prison cause them felons brands them for
the rest of their lives so we have to go
to the back of the line for jobs I can't
vote a whole bunch of places and have
that stigma forever but take your
roommate and just run them through rehab
and put them back into grad school right
that that system the way this operating
I think in the 1970s early 1980s we had
like half a million or less people
behind bars now we have more than two
million not because they've been some
big increase in violent crime but
because we've decided to overlie police
and discriminatorily police these drug
laws now you have a responsibility when
you get out in the world and you're an
employer or you're investing in
companies and
on the forum for all your employees have
you ever been convicted of a felony
check yes no is right there if you check
yes you throw those people in the trash
can remember your roommate who did way
more drugs and snoopy go yet or she had
way more money than Snoopy to do the
drugs but just never got that brand on
his or her head and do justice give
people a second chance in your green
company insist that the green companies
that you champion is in this movement do
justice and don't perpetuate injustice
want to make that point now the other
things I might offend speak too much
more quickly which job should take
priority first of all eventually every
job should be a green job so you know so
we're not we're not going to be
satisfied with some solar panel stuff
this movement is deeper than a solar
panel all right in fact if all you do is
sub out the existing dirty energy for
some cleaning clean energy you really
haven't done that much whew nobody
defend anybody i'ma say it again if all
you do is take the existing dirty energy
and just replace it with some clean
energy you have really done anything use
what you'll have you'll have solar
powered bulldozers solar powered buzz
saws knocking stuff down he'll have
biofuel bombers fighting wars not for
oil for the engines but for lithium for
the batteries and you'll still have a
war-torn horrible human civilization
running off the cliff so eventually the
whole economy has to be green not just
the energy system the whole economy has
to respect creation the whole time he
has to has to be designed right so we
can be here for seven generations or
seven hundred generations the whole
economy but where do we start
your question from my point of view we
have three big opportunities here short
term right now number one we have the
industrial heartland with some of the
most skilled workers in the history of
the world Michigan Indiana Ohio skilled
industrial workers they are not working
many of them are sitting there idle they
can be put to work right away building
things if you're going to go from the
from the economy we got right now to the
next one somebody's got to make a bunch
of stuff right just to keep it as simple
as possible right now how do we power
our society we take dead stuff we take
the bones of our ancestors that's what
Cole is right the dead bones of our
ancestors we take the the dead blood of
our ancestors that's what oil is we take
dead oil and coal out of the ground and
then we burn it without ceremony in our
engines in our power plants and now the
climate scientists are telling us we're
about to get death from the skies you
have a society that is fueled by death
and if we are going to run society based
on living things the living Sun solar
power the wind wind power the waves
title power by the living soil smart
advanced biofuels if we're going to
actually begin to run society based on
living things somebody's got to make
something somebody's got to make that
wind turbine that's smart battery that
solar panel and our industrial workers
should be given the opportunity and the
mandate to get started as a matter of
climate energy emergency there is a it's
a stench in the nostrils of God it is a
crime against future generations to have
a skilled worker sitting idle when we
have all of this work that needs to be
done to begin to prepare for the next
the next economy so Congress needs to
move aggressively to introduce what will
be called a renewable energy standard
also just like a renewable energy goal
to say very clearly that by say 20 30
we're going to be twenty five percent
powered by renewable energy that would
be the biggest jobs program instantly
that you could possibly have that should
be a big priority number two
retrofitting all of our existing
building stock we have a hundred million
homes in America that could be
retrofitted upgraded weatherized so they
waste less energy right now we have a
broken home energy performance market if
for very very poor folks we have a
weatherization program that tries to get
to some of them and if you're really
really rich you can do some remodeling
or you can bring in an energy service
corporation that will do the hospitals
and the universities whatever and you
have a hundred million American homes in
the middle that will never get the help
that they need to get the insulation to
get the high-performance windows so you
get the new boilers to get some new
furnaces to get the insulation to get
all this stuff that would actually cut
their energy bills by thirty percent
forty percent or more with existing
technology right now we have a broken
market nobody's got the money up front
to pay for it and the financing is all
messed up there's a proposal on the
table right now called home star that
will fix it much of that that needs to
move forward that's all 50 states people
could actually be put to work right now
saving people money there's a different
kind of environmental politics we're not
talking about environmental politics
were asking people to spend more money
goodness what we've been doing it's like
here's our environmental politics
briefly according to your cousin hello
you suck please spend more money on our
on tofu or something you know
hello you suck please spend more money
on you know some eco-chic stuff where
are you going come back please be my
friend I mean for ordinary people who
are working every day or want to work
every day the idea that is supposed to
spend more money to be a good person is
really hard what we've got to be able to
do is is is tell people who have
problems who live in crisis that we've
got solutions for them one of them is we
want to cut unemployment in your
neighborhood that's a good thing we want
to put gift snoopy a job that's a real
good thing please give that guy job and
the job we want to give him will
actually cut your energy bill right so
we're going to take the same dollar bill
use it to cut unemployment all right cut
your energy bill which will then make
your coal-fired power plant down the
street work less hard which will cut
pollution right which will therefore cut
asthma our move is trying to take the
asthma inhaler out your little girl's
pocket all right give your neighbor a
job and save you money now will you join
our movement yes you don't have to chase
people down the street with a clipboard
to be a part of that movement all right
and so the second piece is the homestore
piece in the third piece is it's not
just our industrial workers who are
suffering it's not just folks who live
in inner city in urban America who are
suffering our agricultural heartland and
our Native American populations are also
suffering and so if the green economy
can not only help the industrial
heartland recover and help people across
the country and all from all income
levels save money it can also begin to
revive our agricultural and rural
heartland and part of the 80 billion
dollars in the recovery package which I
had a role in overseeing which nobody
talked about was money to USDA was money
to the US Department of Agriculture to
do exactly the kind of things you're
talking about regrading America I forgot
how many billions of dollars we had for
for conservation efforts but the thing
is so horrible which comes back to your
point my friend from Tennessee smart
sane climate policy should be the number
one demand of red state red state
America smart sane climate policy should
be the Republican Party and red state
America should be marching through the
streets of DC of DC demanding smart same
clazziquai if you're a rural farmer
right now you're scared you're
struggling you don't have enough income
if we had the right energy and climate
policy we could deliver three paychecks
to you in on a market basis within a
year number one your role you got your
rural you live you live in rural America
you own some land you could put wind
turbines on that land and get between
five to fifteen thousand dollars a year
just watching them turn now I'd sign up
for that but there's got to be built a
built in demand the pauses have to be
right so you know that you're
is going to be able to connect that to
the grid there's a whole bunch of work
has to be done but the land that's
sitting there you can still keep growing
whatever you growing something else wavy
now that whatever you're growing just
stick three wind turbines there and
you'll get five to fifteen thousand
dollars per per one to watch them turn
once one paycheck number two if you want
to you should be able to grow an energy
crop now I'm not talking about the ones
that we are all mad about but there's
some advanced energy crops that are
coming or could be here or algae that
again in a sane smart climate energy
system should also bring you money
that's the second set of paychecks third
if you do that work the agriculture will
work the smart way with advanced
agricultural techniques where you're
capturing carbon sequestering carbon you
should also be able to play in the
carbon markets join a co-op play in the
carbon market and get paid that way so
in other words the people who were
stopping climate policy are stopping
three different paychecks from going to
their own constituents now we've got to
point that out we've got to do a much
better job of pointing that out now
having gotten to the to all the stuff
you're talking about in terms of the the
new production of clean energy
technology that's going on in the south
and nobody's talking about but the
agricultural heartland in America could
begin to revive based on smart green and
clean policies we need to do a better
job explaining that um so I guess listen
see timber why did I go to the White
House that's a good question who has
that question what's your name cat
that's a good why did why did I go to
the White House
what was he thinking well you know I
spent a lot of time a long time in
politics being mad at the government
Matt the president and demanding that
certain things change and go at a
different direction and we got an
administration that actually agreed with
an awful lot of stuff to people in this
room have been saying and I have been
saying and sometimes guy take yes for an
answer sometimes you gotta take yes for
an answer and given the opportunity to
either continue to stand on the outside
saying what they ought to do you ever
had that conversation is what they ought
to do that's see this is what they ought
to do you know I had that conversation
for a while and I felt like there was an
opportunity to actually be a part of
delivering on what both kids both McCain
and Obama had made strong commitments to
moving in the right direction on Energy
and Climate let's not forget that there
was a a bipartisan consensus in the
debate notice go on YouTube right now
and find John McCain and Senator Obama
fighting about climate and energy policy
I'll wait you won't find it because that
was a one point they agreed on one
hundred percent agree on and it was
clear that there were the you have
majorities in Congress and an
administration that was ready to move in
that direction and so I decided I wanted
to go and be a part of helping and it
was an extraordinary experience people
talk about the fact that i left the
White House vo van you are in the White
House and then and now you're not in the
White House and I can use to stop right
there rewind the tape
to the first party as it is I was in the
White House I got a chance to see
close-up firsthand the challenges his
country faces and the only mean if you
get a chance to serve for 23 minutes do
it I'm serious if you get a chance to
serve for 23 minutes do it because it's
a difference between being in an
airplane where there's turbulence and
sitting with the passengers versus being
in the cockpit and really getting a
chance to see how every single day
America is a miracle this country is a
miracle if you knew how many challenges
come across the radar screen not every
day every hour to have to be responded
to not by robots but by real people in
real time who got kids at home we've got
you know every problem in the world and
to see over and over and over again the
way it not does not step against the
newspapers and all you know everybody
the big debate stuff i mean the daily
challenges of keeping our country safe
keeping our country moving forward
dealing with a short term in a long term
challenges if you you just to get a
chance to see that up close if you think
you love your country now it's it's like
you think you love kids before you have
one and then you really really really
really get it that was my experience and
so I wouldn't trade it for the world um
local funders man first of all who needs
some money in here raising hammers
eating routine all right get him
afterwards um here's the way I would
think about it you don't want to waste
your money I was a lot of talk about
green jobs every answer like you know
it's still a certain kind of a catch
phrase but there's only going to be so
many employers and so many government
programs actually deliver and I think
the most important thing to do
was you know obviously hug the advocates
but what and advocate sometimes the
bridge funding but help them to identify
the employers and make sure they're at
the table because what the employers
need and what the advocates say are
often worlds apart and the the big
challenge I think they were going to
have in the next phase where we're done
with about two-thirds of the green
dollar spend out on the recovery package
except for some of the weatherization
dollars are still there is that as that
money finally hits states and cities and
as the new legislation goes forward
you're going to actually have a business
model starting to break for instant
weatherization the average home
performance company is like you know
three guys in the truck you know like
and they've been doing that for a long
time it maybe do some HVAC on the side
but you know that's their business model
if we want to retrofit a hundred million
American homes those little companies
are going to have to grow pretty fast
and they don't know how and so we might
be over here as advocates screaming
about one set of issues but the actual
employers are likely to have a very
different set and you as a funder the
most powerful movers right now are the
mayor's office and the funders on this
stuff if you have the advocates you got
people who want jobs you got the labor
unions you got the employers but the but
the funders and the mayor's have
convening power so I would number one
make sure the employers were at the
table number to use your convenient hour
to make sure that your funding the
advocates to solve the right problems
and that you're fighting the job
training programs are actually going to
result in jobs so does it leave out any
bodies question okay I question right
here
it's a great question um Jews asking
whether we're talking about blue collar
green jobs or white collar green jobs
and the answer is yes right we're
talking about both as the the great
thing about when you're trying to
transform a whole economy is that you
know somebody can start as somebody
installing solar panels say for instance
and that's their this that's their job
but these industries are going to be
growing and so maybe in a year that go
from being a worker on the crew to being
a crew leader and then they go from that
to being a manager and then maybe go out
and become an owner and inventor and
investor you're talking about green
pathways to prosperity that unlike other
parts of the economy it should not be
hard to make those those leaps in the
health care industry it's hard right
it's hard to go from bedpans to brain
surgeon right that's very difficult can
be done I'm sure it has been done but it
is hard when you're talking about this
kind of stuff repowering and
retrofitting a whole country there
should be green pathways so some people
say we should stop talking about green
jobs and start talking about green
careers that's probably the better way
to think about it we want people to be
able to be a part of the greening of
this country for a long time
she asked question about unions you know
some some are better than others the
laborers union la una has been very
forward-leaning and trying to turn to
trying to figure out how to unionize the
weatherization workforce how to grow and
unionize it and diversify it so I've
shown a lot of leadership at least at
the level of intention you know we still
have a long way to go to kind of
actually sort it out and figure it out
and then the the skill steel workers
have been leaning forward very hard on
the question around wind energy because
they recognize that if we have a strong
policy with regard to wind energy this
is much steel in a wind turbine is it 26
cars all right so they so so some parts
of the labor movement have been really
good yes and luckily so does Arne Duncan
who's the Secretary of Education is a
Big Green Schools Initiative that are
already happening from the grassroots
level but the federal government's also
supportive as well I see a couple hands
how much more time do we have does he
might know how much time yeah do youdo
ok so watch your goodness
yeah the question is what am I going to
do uh well that's a really good question
i mean for me the the good thing is that
the movement has like completely
exploded I mean it's nuts how many
people were part of the green jobs
movement you know three years ago but
say in 2005 when we did the green cities
thing with the United Nations I mean we
were considered way nutty i meanwe nutty
even by the UN you know her like you say
you want what now green jobs and they're
like you say you want what this is like
2005 disliked it like five years ago and
to go from that phase where we were
still just basically evangelizing the
basic concept getting the first products
going 2007 we got the first legislation
passed by the way who's signed into law
the first green jobs act george w bush
so part of the 2007 in an energy bill
that pelosi pushed forward and bush
signed right so is bipartisan good for
red states good for blue states you know
just keep track of this stuff when
people start politicizing stuff
importuning it's nothing it's not look
at the actual history and then you know
we from after 2007's kind of kind of a
big big uptake from there my challenge
now is I get to do a bunch of stuff i
get to advise a bunch of companies that
are great sometimes he's gonna become
household names like a chance to be
there on the ground floor and help them
i also get a chance to advise you know
state local governments and you know
have a role to national a think tank
that has some influence of the guards
the federal government as well i like to
write my like ideas i get a chance to
teach at Princeton so I feel like I'm
confronted with insurmountable
opportunities you know
like insurmountable opportunities in my
field and I haven't decided like what
the next fun thing to do is what I in
terms of like singularly but what I am
excited about is there are so many other
new voices and leaders coming up in the
movement including Phaedra Ellis who now
runs green for all who's extraordinary
that you know it's feel like it's got to
be more like kind of Super Friends you
know lots of people don't let the lots
of cool stuff together so maybe one more
question Wow okay two were questions you
because you have such nice triceps and
you because you're wearing plaid okay go
ahead all right Oh first of all thanks
for being here I actually had the
wonderful opportunity to serve this
administration as well um I did some of
the analytics with a bunch of other
people obviously on the recovery through
retrofit sure mom and I was interested
in that two sentences you said um in the
beating of the documentary make sure to
count what counts but seeing on the back
end the types of analytics I go through
justifying the recovery through retrofit
just simply that that small portion of
its up deals residential housing that
you touched upon I'm wondering from you
what you believe I'm going forward how
do we how do we go about counting what
counts what are the important statistics
and and you've got this this new figure
that that's really new to this whole
scene of what you save that's really not
a hard stat you notice and I'm saying I
mean um if you invest a certain amount
of money and your then recouping to a
point where you've made back that money
and then you're saving it forward how do
you sort of convey that as something
meaningful as opposed to soft savings
gotcha and our print and plaid
providing public goods in the private
sector and I'm wondering why the tea
party is a populist movement right now
instead of your agenda which it seems
has a much broader appeal um well a
couple things one is the to your point
we don't count what counts with our
existing rules regulations and policies
and by that I mean often there are
things that we do that just don't make
any sense if you look at it from a
long-term perspective but from a
short-term perspective they do and one
of the one of the challenges I think
that we've got when the opportunities I
think that we've got is too especially
concretely in the Home Performance
market is to create new financial tools
and new financial services they actually
take into account the long-term savings
and actually to operationalize that into
dr private capital there and that's
actually happening if you look at this
thing called pace which you know all
about but nobody else here does we're
actually there we're actually now
bringing for policy tools and financial
tools so that it actually matters to
bankers this is easy way so it actually
matters to bankers that you're going to
save money on your energy bill the fact
that that you know you could you that
when you weather weather wise in
retrofit your home and will therefore
have more money in your pocket right now
matters to no one including people who
are trying to make you loans for your
house so that is a big as a much longer
conversation but I don't think it's
going to stay abstract it's becoming
much more concrete people want to figure
out how to finance this stuff and one
and people see that there are there are
cost savings to capture and so that part
is moving forward to your point about
about populism and kind of you know
where the pendulum is right now with
regard to populism the
the for lack of a better term there's a
comment an out rate of politics of some
kind of outrage that gets a lot of
attention I think that there's actually
a bigger movement trying to solve the
problems it's just not as loud at this
point and one of the things that I think
you're going to see as things move
forward is actual solutions that help
people in red states and blue states
that can help people who are Republicans
or Democrats those things take longer to
show results but as they show results
they began to leech away some of the
some of the basis of the outrage and so
we're playing a long game here we're not
we're not playing a short short term
game we're playing a long game here if
you look at last year you had the
politics of hope took a year off I don't
you noticed that how hard how hard did
you work in 2008 to elect the President
how hard did you work in 2009 to support
the president one way to ask a question
in 2008 how hard how many emails did you
get from your friends in 2008 trying to
get you to take action do stuff come to
this give money to elect the President
in 2009 how many emails did you get as
people to actually support the president
how many means that you go to 2008 how
many doors did you knock on 2008 how
much work you put in 2008 to elect the
President versus last year 2009 to
support the president the posits of hope
crashed that's what happened you always
had a certain politics of outrage a
certain partly on from a certain you
know into the political spectrum that's
that that's that's that's constant you
had that with the with the clinton
ministration that's Cod that hasn't
changed at all what happened was not
these are the people started doing stuff
is that we stop doing stuff and if you
take that seriously then you don't worry
so much about what the other folks might
be doing or saying you worry about what
are we not doing your nonsense
and the we had literally last year
one-tenth of the intensity to support
the president that we had 2008 to elect
the President you would never even heard
of half of the people you now appear of
all time and so as we go forward I think
we need to keep that in mind and its
ability it's in our hands to revive the
politics of hope and change I'll close
with this hope is very very rare hard
thing to discover to nurture and a half
and change is a thousand times harder to
deliver on and so we are we gotta be
marathoners here I said the last little
talk I'll say it again the best way I
could explain this is when you're
campaigning you're trying to go from the
spirit of hope when you're governing
you're trying to go from hope to change
okay the best example I can give you is
myself not that part of myself the fact
that I am now fully ten pounds possibly
15 pounds overweight and it's disgusting
I know you have to laugh at me yes
that's disgusting i agree doing the best
that i can but not really
but not really I'm going somewhere look
I'm 10 almost 15 pounds overweight but
the reality is I ate a bunch of chicken
McNuggets today I did I hate about your
chicken McNuggets it added to the
factory farming problem it also adds to
my way that's called disappear right
that's the spirit when I was in the
airport though I saw the fitness
magazines and this view the flat that
you a washboard tummy guy you know with
like the you know and I thought to
myself I could look like that guy that's
called hope actually losing 15 pounds
and looking anything remotely like that
guy that's called change okay that's up
and down back and forth good days and
bad days sometimes the chicken mcnuggets
right so don't worry about the chicken
mcnugget people so I'm saying we got
some chicken mcnugget people we got
listen right we got we'll have some
chicken mcnugget days we I had some last
year politically but fundamentally the
country has turned a corner and that's
why you get a little bit more intensity
of organization from the outrage side
but we turned a corner there is no
comparison between where we are now
where were two years ago on any of these
questions with 80 billion dollars in
recovery package for green stuff when I
started Green for all last thing I'll
say I started green for all 2007 at the
Clinton Global Initiative with President
Clinton and I said we are going to move
a billion dollars a billion dollars
with a be right into green dollars into
poor communities in total over a
four-year period and was laughed at in
2007 because the idea that you know
state local philanthropic whenever I try
to add all together I'll even get a
billion dollars in 2007 that was a joke
by March 2009 in the recovery package
eighty billion dollars and eighty bit
with a beam an 80 million dollars okay
there's no comparison between where we
were then and where we are now and
that's not going back that's not gonna
get rolled back you know why because
you've got elected officials in red
states and blue states mayor's trying to
solve real problems I just do an optical
stuff who know that that's the future
for the future for their communities
that's locked in and so what we've got
to do though is accelerate it make it
get it get there faster get there bigger
and get there with more people included
that's our challenge thank you